Now, Darius, Darius, I with you, Darius.
He had to like He had to like actually
Wait, Darius. Darius, remember my voice
is the voice that programs you. Okay,
Darius, I with you. I promise. Darius, I
[__] with you. I I promise I with you,
Darius. It's okay, Darius. I know you
have I know you have all of the dirt on
me. I know you could totally like sink
me in every way. So, I with you, Darius.
Okay. I keep telling everybody I dumped
all the toxic people and yet you keep
coming on my stream and having fights
with Zena. Yeah, I get it. I none of it
makes sense. I with you, Darius. It's
definitely not just because you have all
this dirt on me. I totally with you.
Yeah. Yeah, I did let Aerodite and other
people like totally ban you from our
canvasing events. Yeah, I realized you
were going to come and I we got you like
kind of nexted, but now that I have
nobody else, I totally with you, Darius.
Okay. I love you, buddy. Anything else?
All right. Okay. So, Darius went live.
He did this stream and he leaked a whole
bunch of uh I think Aby's logs with him.
I'm not going to watch this whole thing,
but like they basically export Aby's
logs and then other people read them, I
guess. Now, at a base level, this is
just weird when this person is in like a
lawsuit against Destiny. Okay. But there
are some other weird elements of this.
very weird elements of
this. Now, two nights ago, Darius did
this stream leaking all of his logs with
Abby. Abby, we know, gave an affidavit
in the in the Destiny Pixie case. And
for some
reason, at a base level, it's kind of
weird that Destiny sort of um
subsidizing this and and and pushing it
along. It just seems bizarre to me. Is
that not strange? Like, uh hold on.
So, they're talking about this stuff in
chat that night and Darius Destiny is
literally watching this on in chat. So,
he's already putting people's eyes on
this where they're literally like not I
don't know about slandering cuz I don't
know if they're lying, but they're
they're maligning Abby. They're they're
just bringing up all the things from her
being the roommate there and like on her
and Destiny's in chat like pushing
people. Ivory, tell them to leak more
logs. FFS, leak more logs. Leak all the
logs, dude. leak logs. Is this not
insane when this person's like a witness
against you to be in chat driving
traffic to the stream that's like
actually actively on them and then
telling them to leak more private
information about this
person? That seems
bizarre. Am I
crazy? This like at this exact
time he Oh, sorry. He's responding to
Ivory Destiny Kek. He leaked Abby was
trying to blackmail him with a lawsuit.
Ivory, tell him to leak more logs.
FFS it just seems like
um I don't know why he keeps doing
things like this. It seems very bizarre
to me that he would
um that he would do
this. But anyway, so he was pushing them
all towards this and we'll see right
here. So, as far as I can tell, Darius
unblocks Abby and messages her first.
I don't think you have because
was this embedded in his website? Yes,
he was talking about it while it was
embedded in his website. Yes,
I've been out of my
games era. Anyways, let's get into the
logs. Let's
talk
Darius, make your voice deeper.
So, he's kind of publishing it as well.
I don't know if he's kind of publishing
it or not. Yeah, I'll turn it up for you
guys, but I to me I'm just like very
confused about why this would be
happening.
I'm sure you're you're muting when you
when you talk. Like, let's say Destiny
were actually trying to like um let's
say let's say Destiny were intelligent.
I assume he would want so much distance
from this. I assume he wouldn't want to
be like a part of this so that he
couldn't be accused of of aiding any of
this, but it seems like that's not a
concern to him whatsoever. Yeah. Yeah,
definitely. Definitely.
All right. What characters? What are we
Who's doing what? Who's Abby?
Well, Zip Zip. I got I got Abby. I'm
I'll be You're going to be person's
going to be
see go to when they start reading here.
I'll be Abby.
Oh my god. Please, guys, please. Abby.
Yeah, they're arguing over who the
girl's going to be, right?
Let's keep going. Can you guys
go? So, are we starting at the top about
No, it goes it goes from the It goes
from the bottom up. It goes the the
bottom up. So, you are saying what you
say.
What you say?
That's not what it says. Okay, bro. What
are you doing? What you want? What you
want? It's on your screen. It's on your
screen. You're
You're looking at it. I swear to God.
They make it look difficult. They really
do. The messages say, "What? What you
want?"
For real. What are you doing?
What the [__] are you even talking
about? Walking into my life months later
like you know a single thing. Wait,
don't ask that.
What exactly? Like you're from So, let's
just point out that this is May 1st,
2025.
What are you? It's Wild Darius promotes
his attempts to convince a victim of a
possible crime not to come forward. Yes,
that's I have no idea why he thought
leaking this was a good idea. There's
There's a couple reasons, but I just I
don't get it. I I'm sitting here trying
to figure out what the like 40 chess
play is that could possibly be happening
because to me it just seems insane. This
is after Abby joined the lawsuit. So
this is I believe after Destiny got a
demand letter from her potentially. But
I don't know what Destiny was telling
people and I don't know what Destiny
knew at the time.
We'll we'll just have to we'll have to
go through this and see. Talking about
here. What am I doing? What do you
think, buddy? about messaging Danny just
now. I'm watching Severance. I'll
continue this later.
I'll give you a in-depth synopsis right
now. Intersect is a [__] You owe me at
least the decency to clarify yourself
now. I have a real jobs now. I have to
work tomorrow morning. It's late for me.
Lawsuit, bud. What about a lawsuit? What
do you care at all? Bro, just trying to
figure out what and why. I've known for
a minute, but I figured I'd ask.
Known what? What do you think you know?
You never So, hold on. I I let that go
by. Lawsuit, bud. What about a lawsuit?
Funky boss. Thank you for the new month.
13 months as a sub. Thank you very much,
Funky Boss. Yeah. Lawsuit, bud. What
about a lawsuit? Why do you care at all,
bro? Just trying to figure out what and
why? I've known for a minute, but I
figured I'd ask, bro. Just trying to
figure out what and why. I've known for
a minute, but I figured I'd ask.
Known what? What do you think you know?
You never even knew me or bothered to
care about me. All right, then. I'm not
going to argue to people about my
feelings towards them at any point in
time. Whatever you feel, buddy.
You have to try to at least understand
my hostility. You hurt me the same as I
might have hurt you. I know you how you
feel about me. Like to begin with, it's
already kind of bizarre for Darius to do
this. I believe at some point here, he
literally promises her that he would not
leak this for content on his stream. So
like he he literally promised he's like,
"Yeah, no, no, no. I won't do that. I
won't I won't release this on stream."
Uh Downey has subscribed. Thank you,
Downey. Thank you. 4 months. Let's go.
I've been I don't know why I started
reading like the message instead of just
saying thank you, but thank you. I want
really to know
why. Also, out of the blue, I'm calm.
Promise. I didn't know you were talking
about the lawsuit. I have not been
following it publicly. I apologize.
Besides, when you banned me, I haven't
been watching or keeping up online much.
I have a busy life now. And I don't mean
to be aggro. I have a lot of resentment
and feelings I've had to heal from when
it came to you that were traumatic. And
I wholeheartedly do not expect you to
ever see you have the capability to have
these conversations or ever care. So,
if you have questions, ask, but I'll not
let it be. You're or leaked. You're not
joining the lawsuit.
Will you be making anything I tell you
public?
No.
Like, I don't know. Does does Darius
really I I feel like this person is
like it's
I can't stress how much he deserves like
everything that's happened to him. Like
he is he is earned. There's no in no way
is he a victim in any part of his life.
Any bad thing that's happened to him he
is totally earned
um in like every possible way. Rude. I
am. Yes.
Unless I'm given permission.
Why? I have plenty. Yes, Cyberdrifter.
Yeah. So, sorry I'm not sowing out yet
cuz I haven't presented the content, but
yes, that is what this is all about.
That is what this is all for. It is
purely to try to discredit Abby. Not
even necessarily to discredit her, but
to try to intimidate her out of
appearing as a witness, unironically,
because I believe what these guys are
saying is like, well, you know, when we
were roommates, we have things we could
sue you for. Remember when you did this?
Remember when you did that? Maybe if you
sue Destiny, maybe we'll sue you.
I was like, "Okay, a valid reason." All
right. Like, don't agree. My media being
shared. Don't find out until that's a
little that's a little bit of uh that's
a little bit of a spoiler for later in
the conversation, but we'll get to
there. This is coercion, is it not? It
certainly looks crazy to me. I don't
know how a judge interprets this. I'm
just going to put together this timeline
for people a little bit, and then we'll
uh we'll we'll figure everything out.
Okay. Did Abby live with them? Abby used
to live with uh Darius and Legacy.
Yes. Uh I believe they they've accused
her of some pretty bad things, but
again, they can go to court over them, I
guess, if they want to. January,
we turned up just a titch more. Yep. You
offered me to see Destiny naked like 15
times.
And videos of you and him. I rejected,
but you were doing so much. It just
seems weird.
You can do whatever you want though. I
don't think lawsuit will help anything.
If you feel like you want compensation,
I just DM
Steven. Uh, that seems weird, right? If
you feel like you want compensation, I
just DM
Steven. That seems bizarre. Also, he's
he's like, "Oh, you did this thing,
too." Which, by the way, Destiny, if she
did that, Destiny could sue her, right?
Destiny could just sue her. Anyway,
scenario for you, it seems.
Did you actually see them? Did I show
them to you? Did I send them to you? No.
Was I an alcoholic piece of flaunting I
had it to you? Yes. He shared mine with
a lot of people I didn't know about
until recently and more. You weren't
flaunting. You were going to show me
until I literally told you that. Sounds
like if she did that, she wouldn't
deserve compensation. Hm. Uh well, one
uh those things could be litigated, I
think, separately,
or you would show proof. But here, um I
think both Darius and her acknowledge
she didn't actually share it.
So, unfortunately, this proves literally
nothing. Uh except that maybe Abby was
like kind of a piece of and willing to
violate people's consent, too. But
unfortunately, that doesn't make her
testimony invalid, and it doesn't make
her claim against Destiny invalid. So,
unlucky.
Oh, whoops. I was You can't justify that
action just because you were drunk.
Well, thank you for stopping me. Yes, it
was wrong of me. I'm glad I was a
21-year-old on this one. I just want to
I just want to point out that
um Darius
literally took this girl who he
obviously had kind of like a spell over.
Like she clearly even though he's super
harmful, he's harmed her significantly.
I believe we've had multiple people post
the images of Darius choking her in the
Discord.
Okay. Uh they've harmed each other, but
she has like a thing for him and she's
clearly like under a spell. She's
willing to do whatever just to talk to
him, right? And he's using that to leak
these DMs for Destiny's sake. Kind of
putting a weird spotlight on Destiny and
absolving Abby of the crime he wants to
commit uh like uh what do you call it?
Accuse her of at the same time. Like
it's actually it's almost
it's almost like poetic irony that he's
like trying to help and he's like
Destiny by
himself. It's it's weird. It's it's it's
almost poetic. Absolutely. Damn. Well,
but I didn't show you, bro. What? Or
anyone is the point. I don't even
remember if you did. That's not the
point. What's the point? You were
willing slash did show this content to
someone. you were without their
permission. You're mad at Steven for
doing the same or joining a really
[__] about it. I just message Steven
about it instead of tying yourself to
this. If you want money out of it, just
message him. High chances you get
nothing out of this except wasting your
time and
resources. So, here's the
thing. There's no way that Destiny
reached out to Darius about Abby, right?
There's no way that he would reach out
to this
utter and go, "Hey, can you talk to Abby
for me? I heard she's like a witness or
something. I heard she's like getting
involved in these lawsuits. Hey, Darius,
could you like could you go figure out
what's going on?" There's no way he said
this, right? There's no way. Except
unfortunately in like the in the very
short period of time before this, it it
appears there are references. Okay. Do
we remember when Darius and Zena went on
Destiny's stream? Do we remember this?
Have we heard about this? Do we remember
this? Where Darius was crashing out
about Zena saying she had a an STD. Do
you remember this? You tell. Now, this
is on May 2nd. So, I think I think this
could be from this one from from this
day. I think it is. But speaking a
totally different voice and speaking
completely different. Shut up. Shut up.
2023 vibes. Uh oh, that's where my
life's currently stuck at. So, we Okay,
well, you're good with it. So, I'm
debating if I So, once I say it, it's
dark. So, I'm just I'm giving it a
second to think. Okay. Wait, also this
is nothing until you represent, right?
No, it's nothing to do with that. It's
All right. What do you got?
Huh?
Huh? So, the day after these DMs are
getting sent,
he says, "This is nothing to do with uh
what I've been talking to you about,
right?
There's nothing. Hold on. There's
nothing to do with that, right?
Whoa. Whoa. D. Wait, Darius. Hold on.
There's nothing. Oh, don't worry, Jacob.
I've got that,
too. That's
strange. That's very H. Now, I I'm not
particularly given to conspiracy, but it
almost seems like there was some foot.
But we actually met Hold on, hold on,
hold on. We had Wes come on on the
third. Oh, sorry. Yes, the 3rd of May.
Okay. Published on the 4th, but it was
on the 3rd of May. Okay. That was weird.
He actually messaged me the other day.
He was like, "What?" And I was like,
"What?" He's like, "Did Abby ever show
you or tell you that?" Hold on. What did
he say? It was I was like, "Where the
coming from?" So now I'm just hearing
this and it's starting to make sense. He
said, "Did Abby ever show or send you
any videos of us hooking up?" And I was
like, "What? No. What the?" Now I'm
getting where it's coming from.
Very
huh.
Huh.
Wow. Very, very interesting. Now, it
seems odd to me
now. I don't know. It seems It just
seems odd to me that Destiny's been so
desperate. Not that. Okay, let me just
tell you, okay, maybe there's some world
where this could be okay. I'm not
totally sure, but who knows? All
right. Um, maybe there's some world
where where this could make sense, but I
don't understand why he'd be so
desperate to reach out personally
instead of having his lawyers reach out.
I don't understand why he'd be this
desperate. Unless Abby had seen some or
been sent some like I I just it doesn't
make any sense to me that you'd be this
sloppy cuz then lawyers know better. I
Yeah, it's very strange to me, right?
It's very very very strange to me that
he would do this. I don't I actually
don't understand. So, he had reached out
to both Wes and Darius. I believe he had
talked to somebody that was speculated
to be a douche in the uh in the DG chat
as well. Where was Do I have these logs
somewhere? Let me see. Destiny
Abby. So, there's some logs here where
he's talking to somebody here.
Somebody's trying to ping him. Oh, wait.
Legacy Rose, are you the one who
messaged me like a year ago talking
about Abby? How Abby was looking for
ways to get money out of me way back
when? I'm trying to remember who the
messaged me talking about
this. So, this is on Well, this is
actually a day or two ago.
What? Oh, maybe this is a Wait, are
there multiple logs of this? I'm not
totally sure. In any
case, it's very strange. This whole
timeline is very strange. Okay, this is
uh just recently. No, no, no. There was
another thing where he was talking to
somebody, but I can't remember the name.
Anyway, if somebody wants to find that
screenshot for me, it' be interesting.
There was another point where he talked
about how Abby was crazy because Abby
had reached out to him. I don't know if
you guys remember this. I believe this
was on stream where he said, "Bro, this
this girl's like crazy." It might have
been a DG chat, but it was like, "She
she messaged me out of nowhere. She
messaged me out of nowhere."
It's like, oh, well, apparently Darius
was saying if you message Steven, you
can work out a deal outside of the
courts or
something. I wonder where Darius got
that idea from, but who knows? Who
knows? Who knows? Who knows? You think
this stuff is making Pixie's case
stronger? I think it has to be. No.
Like, it might Well, hold on. I don't
know cuz I don't know if they'd ever be
able to subpoena stuff around this. It
certainly seems concerning to me, but
obviously we have a lot of context that
it would be hard to deliver effectively
to a judge. And I don't know. I'm just
not totally sure,
right? I'm actually just not
sure. But it seems to me like there's
some weird going on here in terms of
this timeline of Darius reaching out and
saying these things. I have no idea why
Darius leaks these logs. It looks so bad
to leak these
logs. Lol. Letting manipulate you. At
least Darius is self-aware. Oh, dude.
You So, let's just read this again. you
were willing/ did show content to
someone you were with without their
permission. So, she said she didn't.
Darius says she didn't. So, he's like
trying to paint it in a different way.
So, she's saying, "No, no, no, I
didn't." Which, by the way, is why Abby
should never have talked to her because
Darius is trying to use this uh this
hold he has over her to get her to
confess to things that she may not have
even done, right? Like, he's trying to
drive her in that direction. She should
never have reached out to this guy. This
guy's like totally bad. Doesn't care
about you. Doesn't give a about you.
Don't talk to Darius, okay? He will do
whatever he can to make sure Destiny is
safe, including you over, so be very
careful. Uh, or joining a really lawsuit
about it. I'd message Steven about it
instead of tying yourself to this. If
you want money out of it, just message
him. High chances are you get nothing
out of this. He doesn't know any of
this, by the
way. Or remember, because she was or is
an alcoholic. I think she's been sober
for a while, but like she did have
substance abuse issues. I'm sure there's
like bad things Abby has done. I'm sure
I think they go over some of them in
this stream. I don't really want to air
them because I'm not going to
participate in that. But I do believe
she's done some bad things. I just don't
think that like makes her I don't think
that affects her testimony, right? Just
in the same way. Oh, hold on. This is
apparently the logs right here. Oh, this
is apparently Nadouch talking. Uh
Destiny, I'm going to bed soon. If you
want to talk about a then just DM me.
This is on May 4th.
Uh, Sushia. So, asking sushi, is it
about a Destiny? Call me really fast. I
have something to say about you know who
Destiny talk to
Nadouch. So, this is Nadouch coming in
and saying like Destiny, I'll leak you
all the things about Abby. By the way,
Nadouch infamously schizotiple chatter
who like is was literally perma banned
from Destiny's sub from everything. Like
literally gone from
everything. What does I've seen all the
drives and all the tapes of everyone
else too mean? Uh, have we gotten to
that log
yet? Uh, I think so. I can't tell if
this is because she was sent stuff.
Darius claims it was because she was
snooping through his computer. I'm
actually not sure. It's not clear from
these logs what actually happens here.
So, we'll take a look. Well, you can
just message Destiny for money. Does
that work? Okay. Sorry. I don't even
want the money. What he's doing has done
seems I've seen all the drives and the
tapes of everyone else, too.
letting manipulate you is funny.
They pulled me in. You did the same
thing. You literally showed the same
stuff. I get you've seen his stuff
because you went through. But she didn't
do that. She literally claimed she
didn't do that. And Darius Darius
literally said, The funny thing is is he
started this. It's so transparent what
he's trying to do, right? He's trying to
get her to say she did so he can send
those logs to people. It's so
transparent.
But she already said, Darius already
said, "Well, I told you not to send them
to me." And she's like, "Yeah, thank
you. Thank you for making me not send
them or whatever. And it's like, okay,
yeah, it's it's like literally nothing
happened. And now he's like now he
realized that looks bad. So he's trying
to get her to something. I forget he
literally took a picture of it off his
PC, which is again his business. I don't
see how that's negative that he has
points of people he's been with. What
are you doing? You don't care about me.
You don't care about Kro. What am I
doing? It's been months. Who are you
protecting, Steven? Why do you care?
Really? Good response. I don't really
care. I just think it's a and you're
adding yourself to more autistic
again. It's his business. I don't see
the negative that he is. Those people
he's been with. What are you doing? You
don't care about me or about Gavin. It's
been months. Who are you protecting? Why
are you protecting Steven? Why do you
care? Maybe you like it at this point. I
don't care. Good luck. This isn't Game
of Thrones. I'm not trying to protect
anything. It's just annoying that you're
yet again coping and doing the tardy. It
seems nobody around you is able to put
together the parallels. But it's okay.
Surely it'll be epic.
I really hope one day. Oh, uh, the
Nadouche guy. Somebody sent me a picture
of Nadouche was Nadouch in Destiny
before he was
banned. Nadouche infamously the the guy
who set up Grace Thorp to walk away from
Darius and have Darius have a like
actual autistic rage
meltdown. Cool, cool, cool, cool. These
are these are, by the way, these are
Desty's primary shooters now, right? All
of the people he banned for being way
too schizophrenic who stuck around,
these are Destiny's primary shooters.
Okay, these are the guys. These are his
best guys now. The top guys. When you
can heal more, you realize the pain you
can cause to others.
Ironic.
Yes, I think I'm further than you, which
is ironic from what I've seen on the
sadness of your streams. But go ahead,
get triggered and block me again like
always. I'll never have closure from
you. I don't need it. I'm on the right
path. But I do hope you'll realize the
effect you can have on others sometime.
I am too. Trust. If you realize that,
you wouldn't send weirdass paragraphs to
people about how much better you're
doing. Good chat.
Dude, what? I did that because I have
money and I wanted to pay back the most
reasonable person on the lease, Danny.
So, it sounds like she did message Danny
about paying extra damages and talk
about our relationship. I'm not even
being stubborn. I'm not totally sure
where this goes from here. I can't
remember. You're being so open. You're
being so mean, dude. If I hurt you that
bad, I'm very sorry. I've seen you call
me fat, a wench, whatever. It hurts
still. I know you'll hate me that I've
accepted it. Except I'm moving on my
life and I'm not dead like I tried to be
multiple times. I need serious help. You
hurt me too
much. Still, you wouldn't give me the
time a day. You never did other than now
suddenly in the Am I the Am I the only
person who's like feels like if I if I
had somebody who like trusted me this
much? This would like
actually tear me up. Even if I didn't
really like the person, if they trusted
me this much that they were going to
tell me like all these super private
things, I feel like there's no way I'd
go on a public stream and air their logs
out. Like like I can't imagine how like
that that cuts pieces of your soul off,
right?
We did. Yeah, we did pass one of the do
not leaks. Like that actually shaves
pieces of your soul. Like doing stuff
like that, like taking somebody's trust
who trusts you this much that they'll
just take your word for it and then
abusing that trust. That is that
absolutely rend the soul. Okay. It's not
good. Darius is too loyal to Destiny to
care about anyone else. Yeah, I know. I
know. I know. It's very sad. It's very
sad stuff. The interest of Steven. I
know. It's Abby. She's a person. Yeah. I
just I don't see the world like that. I
guess. Yeah. I don't I'm a terrible
person. I know I'm a terrible person to
you. Don't message me unless you're
interested or ever care about the pain
you caused me and how I retired. Aras is
a soulless base. Thank you very much for
that message. I'm just recommending you
probably don't do the lawsuit thing.
Seems pretty. And when you find a
history to say, you'll show me your
photos of Stephen. It isn't a good look.
What kind of legal argument is that? You
said you'd send me something. So, you
know what? You suing him for for
actually breaking the law there. That's
not a good look, actually. That's just
not a good look. Okay. Very bad look for
you. No interest in talking about our
personal relationship as I don't believe
you've changed, nor do I care to ask it
at the moment, as it was like 6 months
ago.
Are you saying you'd openly testify
against me, or are you saying you'd tell
your stream that I'm not worried about a
good look? I'm saying exactly what the
what I typed. What the are you
interpreting, bro? This isn't a
detective game. This isn't Among Us.
What the do I care about? A good look,
dude. What are you going to tell your
300 botted viewers? Oh, damn. On your
lame. Oh, damn. Show. Come on now. What
events do you have that will stand in
quite a lot that I would By the way, I
will just say Darius regularly has like
250 viewers and like three chatters,
like three active chatters. This is just
a fact, unfortunately. Okay. I didn't
really want to pick at him over it, but
yeah, when he goes and works out,
there's nobody chatting, but he has 250
viewers,
right? Like, it's just very, very, very
obvious and transparent what's going on.
Acting will not look good. Is that a
threat? I've not looked good. I do not
care. Thank you, though. You're dead,
sweethearted.
What do you think? It'll give me money.
What do you think? I should just give
up. I think you should eat lol.
Dude, do you have a minute to call? I'm
a bad texter. Yeah, real. Are you for
real? Oh my god. I know you may not
believe this, but I'm generally out of
the blue and confused. So, when you
unblock me, I did not immediately know
what you were talking about, and the
shock of you doing this so casually
threw me off. For this, I am sorry. I
have a job to work early in the morning.
Please do not tell me to eat or that you
wish the worst for me. I don't care what
your opinion is of about me. I know you
have the empathy to understand with the
history we have, and that hurts me. You
can tell me to eat all you want forever,
but if me doing this with the lawsuit
hurts you enough in any capacity, I'd
reconsider. If you can be h dude, this
is just brutal, right? Like I feel
like I feel like she badly wants Darius
to just be her friend to tell her it's
okay. Like this is just sad to me.
Reasonable and try to talk to me
cohesively and normally not. Dude, what
are you doing after how many months? I
don't want to hurt you and I was never
planning on it. I promise. Please don't
do that. We can be adults. You reached
out for a reason. Don't back down from
that. We can talk. Move on with life. If
you have an issue with what Steven did,
I would suggest reaching out to him. And
if you feel obligated to something for
it, I just ask him. Seems way better and
more reasonable than the lawsuit. I
don't think you do anything but garner
negative attention to yourself. And if
you're trying to get away from this
stuff, it just seems kind of By the way,
if you feel obligated to something,
that's not what the word obligated
means. Darius doesn't know even know.
Not shocking that Darius would actually
just not know the definition of
obligation. That really just that's
actually just a perfect character fit,
isn't it? Productive. If you didn't
manage to if you didn't attempt to do
the same behaviors he did, I probably
wouldn't have a problem with you doing
whatever, but it looks very backwards
when you would have done or have done
the same thing if I gave you consent.
Uh, hold on, hold on one second. Uh, I
think Abby was/ is incredibly vulnerable
for multiple reasons. People may not see
that or want to see it, but it doesn't
change the facts. This all just played
into Destiny's usual pattern of
behavior. Yeah, I just don't understand.
Okay, like I I posted a message in um in
my general chat earlier, but I'll I'll
read it cuz it just it's like literally
how I feel about this. Hold
on. Oh, one second. Let me find
it. This is like basically what I
imagined Darius saying. Wow, I can't
believe this girl who apparently has
zero self-esteem and significant
substance control issues did bad things.
Anyway, I'll accept her cleaning my room
so she can suck my for the ninth time.
And then I'm totally done with her. I'm
nexting her after that. And then it was
the 10th time. And then it was the 11th
time. It was like this like he's
perfectly happy with having somebody
who's like sort of like broken and
vulnerable around him when it serves
him. And then as soon as they're gone
and they they they're angry, it's like,
"Oh, they're totally broken. No, that
don't listen to them. Don't trust them."
No. What? Have you heard that they're a
do you not know that they're an insane?
And it's like, dude, how the you can't
be somebody who who constantly takes
advantage of people like this and then
go, wait, they're saying something bad
about me now. No, they're totally
insane. It just doesn't make any logical
sense.
There is, do you be using words like
garner offream? Is that real? Okay, good
word. I appreciate that. Thanks. I'll
reconsider. But again, why do you care?
You could have left me alone forever.
You know, you should have and wanted to,
but just for Steven, right? or because
I'm stupid and you want me to realize
this and be right. I don't think this
helps, Stephen. If anything, it hurts
someone messaging you about what you're
doing. Why then? Seems like I'm a goon.
Cuz it's annoying to see you constantly
self-destructing, buddy.
Why does he want Danny? Yeah, I scrubbed
your screen chat. Does it have to do
with me? Crazy odds. I just reached out
to Danny prior. No relation. No idea. I
was just baiting.
Okay, thanks. Good to know. Well, I'm
not doing this anymore nearly as much as
you seem to care since you reached out.
I really am doing better. I don't know
why you assume based on this one convo I
haven't changed at all when I think
we're basically done with like the
interesting parts of this. It's chill. I
got involved in this case in January. I
was still drinking a bit. It's been a
long drawn out. I will point out that
Darius also knew how bad these logs
looked like a couple weeks ago because
he leaked the later part of these logs
on his stream a couple weeks ago. Like
two weeks ago, right? And now he's I
don't understand why he's leaking this
part. It actually looks so pass. You
randomly assumed I was threatening you
and tried to call my stream honor
botted.
I don't care.
She called his stream botted. And that's
the thing that sticks in his mind, isn't
it? He's like that. That was her really
digging the knife in. Okay. That's the
thing that actually him off here. Not
any of the crimes, not any of the
consent violations. You call my stream
botted. It's not
botted. God. Oh, uh, somebody just
wanted to link this this funny little
log. So, apparently Destiny was totally
out of this. Destiny was like, "Listen,
this is really weird, gross behavior."
Rick, I don't trust any of these people.
There's a reason why in 2024 I was
largely separated from basically all of
them. Way too much went back room log
sharing/dumping/coordinating/weird [__]
And now we have Destiny sitting in chat
saying,
"Darius, get Darius to dump more logs.
Get Darius to leak more logs. Darius
leak. Darius
leak." And then what happened the other
day? Wasn't Darius like getting
self-conscious and he's like you you
like didn't like me before? You're like
you like kind of just only started
hanging out with me now. And he's like
Darius. Darius I with you. Darius. He
had to like he had to like actually wake
Darius. Darius remember my voice is the
voice that programs you. Okay. Darius I
with you. I promise. Darius I with you.
I promise I with you. Darius. It's okay.
Darius. I know you have I know you have
all of the dirt on me. I know you could
totally like sink me in every way. So I
[__] with you, Darius. Okay, I keep
telling everybody I dumped all the toxic
people and yet you keep coming on my
stream and having fights with Zena.
Yeah, I get it. I none of it makes
sense. I with you, Darius. It's
definitely not just because you have all
this dirt on me. I totally with you.
Yeah. Yeah, I did let other people like
totally ban you from our canvasing
events. Yeah, I realized you were going
to come and I we got you like kind of
nexted, but now that I have nobody else,
I totally with you, Darius. Okay, I love
you, buddy. Anything else? Anything
else, buddy? If you don't believe this,
I might have done the same all to you
guys, but I have lots of trauma. Yes, I
keep mentioning it. Please consider that
having Please, please consider having
that patience. This gave me an anxiety
tech. I have to take a
sand. That's a defensive mechanism
aggression. I'm sorry it happened. Uh,
someone asked, "Who is Abby here in the
Twitch chat?" I missed this. Sorry about
Sorry about that. The normie 215. Abby
is Darius's former roommate. Thankfully,
Destiny leaked who Abby was. So, we we
knew.
All right. Darius was banned from
attending events. Darius was supposed to
come to the event. I believe they set up
a chaperone for him. I said Erdite, but
I actually don't know. They set up a
chaperone for him and then basically
people were like, "You know what?
Actually, we don't want you at this
event. You shouldn't come to this
event." And he didn't get to go. They
kicked him out and I took his side. I
said, "That's up of you guys. I said
that's up. You guys banned Darius when
you actually set up him going. You got
his hopes up and now you banned him.
That's actually
super Destiny. Do you remember when uh
the Molina was going down and you
Darius, sorry, you Destiny, you totally
sunk D. You didn't take Darius's side at
all. Even though you did believe him.
You knew he was telling the truth in a
bunch of those cases. Okay. Didn't take
his side at all. You didn't take his
side whatsoever. And you just ban him.
You you let him be abused by your by
your community for like months and you
just ban him from your events. That's
up, dude. Why would you take a side? He
was obviously going to be creepy there
at the minimum. Yeah, but there's like
three women that would be there in the
first place, so there's just not really
that much risk. When there's like 900
guys and three women, he just there's
too many eyes on
him. And Nick was supposed to be with
him. So, I'm I'm sure Nick would have
kept him from being a total creep. Do
your thing. I'm happy for your stream or
whatever. was an insult. Shouldn't have.
Please don't make me your content
anymore. I've seriously been through
enough of that. I really hope that some
part of you doesn't hate me, can
understand how badly this has affected
me. And I really hope that there's a
reasonable part of you can still under
you think Darius feels like any amount
of guilt here whatsoever for like like
when they read messages like this. Does
anybody not like feel this at all? Like
like apparently that there's a bunch of
people viewing this stream. Do they not
see that this is like just like you're
I'm sorry, but you you are actually like
you're hurting your soul. Like you you
are actually cutting pieces off of it,
doing like horrible things to other
people. I hope I hope some of them
realize this. You would hope, but who
knows? Understand? Everything I did and
every everyone I hurt was because I
could not handle my pain and I was an
addict. Oh my god. Okay, there's more.
I've accepted I'll never be forgiven by
you or Hayden. I'm really okay living
with that and one day I won't sad. I
don't expect you to understand or ever
forgive me at all. I'm still in the
process of forgiving myself. You should
too. I don't know what to do now. So,
I'm ser to my boy Gavin. Now I couldn't
give a You realize she lives with Gavin
right now, right? Baked till crisp. Like
her and Gavin are
dating. Do you not realize that or they
ran away together?
What do you what do you
what I'm seriously after you said I got
involved at first to help the others
involved. I did not think the
possibility to message him myself. What
do you think would happen? I'm scared.
I'm at work. I can't explain more now.
Maybe later. Just have a good day. I
don't think you need to be scared.
Steven is a Just message him. Okay.
Okay. Well, in short, can't talk now. My
lawyers want to sign want me to sign a
couple final documents today and I have
to print them after work and get them in
by midnight. Well, think about it. It's
been a long process. I'm reconsidering.
Don't talk to him or tell him that he's
asking or fishing about me. All right,
but I probably don't talk to him or tell
him that he is asking or fishing about
me.
What? My lawyers want me to sign a
couple final documents today and I have
to print them after work and get them in
by midnight.
dude after work and sorry I was uh
reading chat and I didn't see uh I
didn't see this but yeah I don't think
you need to be scared if Steven is a
just message him he's literally
leveraging every part of his personal
relationship to try to get her to stop
right to try to get her to um to stop
joining this lawsuit get them in by
midnight think about it it's been a long
process I'm reconsidering don't talk to
him or tell him that he's asking or
fishing about me all right but I'd
probably just message him before you
finalize anything yeah that's what I
plan to It's a bit hard to reach out
after so many months and be like, "Hey,
I'm involved." So, you know, this might
get Should I just cut you the slack and
move on? I have to think about this.
Seriously, I've made it very far
legally. So, uh, no. Just tell him your
issue and ask him what you feel like
you're owed so you feel like you can
handle it out of court, lol. Instead of
causing a PR nightmare for everyone
involved.
Okay. Thanks for that advice, Darius.
I'm shocked you care to give it. Oh my
god, bro. I wouldn't be I wouldn't be a
PR nightmare for me. For him only,
possibly you. Cope him. It'd be easy
content for me. So, not really.
But you're right. I can and have thought
plenty times to abandon this and move on
with my life. My lawyers call every week
and rope me back in. Please just don't
right now, bro. Not until I find out. By
the way, my lawyers My lawyers quote
unquote all my lawyers. Pixie lawyers.
only she does is like personally do
these guys not understand that she is
like filing a lawsuit against Destiny uh
for the same thing or Destiny sharing
the pictures in the the same way he did
video in the same way that he did or
maybe it's just media I can't remember I
can't remember what it said in the in
the affidavit but like it's the exact
same thing exact same statute
yeah anyway okay that's the only PR that
Abby knows that yeah that's just typed
in chat this combo was made first and
they filed
wouldn't be a PR night for mayor for me.
Only possibly uh for me only him
possibly you. Wait a second. Yeah. Uh
Aby's literally saying this in by
midnight. She's lally talking the night
before. Hey, she's reconsidering the day
before.
Insane, dude.
Uh probably annoying for him, but yeah.
I mean, if you want to do that to him. I
I love how not to be rude, but poor
people, how they interact with like like
lawsuits and stuff like that. I I like
this. It's very funny. Probably annoying
for him. But yeah, I mean, if you want
to do that to him, go ahead. But if you
want to gain anything from this,
messaging him would be better. The
lawsuit seems pretty bunk. True. I've
known for like two months, so I'm chill.
What? Based on what? I just I don't even
know. I don't think these guys
understand what they're talking about
whatsoever.
I usually don't.
You don't know a lot, man. No offense.
Unless I don't know. Maybe my been
leaked. Talk later. Maybe I could tell
you. I'm got to work. Just realize you
don't know the full extent or details at
all. I didn't even until recently, and
I'm still learning. Thank you. I don't
want to do anything to anyone anymore.
Please, believe me, I was only
attempting to help Pixie and others
leaked. And yes, my been leaked a lot,
too. I didn't know about Lucky. Not
public. It's just been a long drawn out
process these months. I've been over it
and I want it resolved too. It's going
to be drawn out even long.
Dude,
it's I all I can really think is if the
lawsuit's so bunk, why is Destiny
risking something by trying to reach out
to people to get information about one
of the people accusing him? If it's just
if Pixie's lawsuit has no legs, if Aby's
lawsuit would have no legs, why is he
risking this in any way?
Are you risking reaching out to total?
Uh, one second. I just had to send a
message really quickly. You don't know a
lot, man. No offense. Unless I don't
know, maybe my been leaked. Talk later.
Maybe I could tell you. I'm got to work.
Just realize you don't know the full
extent or details at all. I didn't even
until recently, and I'm still learning.
Thank you. I don't want to do anything
to anyone anymore. Please, believe me, I
was only attempting to help Pixie and
others leaked. And yes, my been leaked a
lot, too. I didn't know about Lucky, not
public. It's just been a long drawn out
process these months. I've been over it
and I want it resolved, too. It's going
to be drawn out even longer as well.
Like I said, just DM him and tell him
I'm the issue.
Okay, I will. Thanks, man. You don't
think he'll attack me or tell me to off?
I thought the legal way was more mature,
professional. Oh, man. I don't know if
you think he won't be hostile.
Whatever. That's not your place to tell
me. Uh you
whatever that means. I don't know. You
want me to have a good day? Uh it's
going to be long drawn out even longer.
I said, like I said, just DM him and
tell him the issue,
bro. Okay. I'm not familiar to with the
case, but if Darius is part of the case,
it's going to be a [__] show. Darius is
not part of the case. But if you were
here a little bit earlier than normie,
we showed two clips where Destiny was
reaching out to people like Darius and
Wes, by the way, and asking for
information on Abby. And for some
reason, Darius, after being reached out
to decides to go over to Abby and start
messaging her at saying like, "Just
message Destiny about this. If you want
some money, just message Destiny,
right?" Like I Yeah, not yet. Yeah. I
basically that's what it is. Like this
this looks so [__] bad.
highly doubt he will.
Okay, I'll be reasonable and try that
lawyers have advised against it. I don't
want him to turn around and use it
against me in court and [__] with me if
I do talk to him. Like, surely my
lawyers would me, but if I settle with
it, if I settle it with him and avoid
everything else and move on, I will. And
hopefully Pixie and everyone else will
be okay. Yeah, let me know how it goes.
Stay as professional as I can be. I I
don't want to get for this actually cuz
it gets like it gets bad. She like talks
a lot. So like if you like have like
help you but she talked a lot and just
kind of one side of response.
Apparently my lord would kill me but if
I can settle it with him and avoid
everything else and move on I will. I
think this is like if you message
somebody, there's no way. I I don't
believe that Destiny would be enough to
message Darius and say, "Hey, like point
her in this direction." There's no
possible way. It's actually like it's in
my mind it's like impossible, but he
could have said like talk to Abby. Yeah.
Oh my god. I just It's so so dumb. I
don't know why you would leak anything
that would push people in this direction
to think that this could happen.
But like, yeah, now now she's been
convinced. And then I believe after
this, Destiny says something like, "Oh,
she messaged me." And she's like, "Uh,
she's totally crazy. I have no idea why
she would message me instead of lawyers.
I don't even know if she's allowed to do
that."
No, I'm chilling. I'm a lock in. I got
it. Just got to clear my throat here.
I'm looking at a big old do not leak
this. So, Oh, boy.
state as professional as I can be. I
don't want to get for this. You can
seriously turn around and me with this.
But yeah, kind of glad you reached out.
I was contemplating further. Anyway, by
the way, I wasn't going to leak this.
Only reason. Okay. Uh the only reason
he's leaking it is
remember remember Oh, hold
on. The only reason he's leaking it is
this. Ivory, tell him to leak more logs.
Right. This is why he's leaking it. So
he's like, "Oh, I totally wasn't gonna
leak this, but he leaked Abby was trying
to blackmail him with a lawsuit. Ivory,
tell him to leak more logs. FS. That's
why he's leaking it." Because Destiny
asked him to leak
it. Destiny, the person who is in the
lawsuit, the person who is being sued by
Abby and Pixie, or I don't know about
Abby yet. I don't know if there's a
formal complaint yet, but like that's
who asked him to leak more logs and then
he did.
There is death idiot. Okay, first off, I
didn't anybody. I'm as you see, but
okay, I'll be honest. My messages here
aren't the best. But I honestly have I'm
very hostile to this person cuz I'm very
mad at them. But two, about it. Two, I
was not going to leak any of this and I
was going to not I was going to leave it
alone. But then she said she's going to
she's going to talk to her lawyers about
me and put me in jail. I was like, this
dude, she said she's going to have a
domestic assault charges on me. I'm
like, okay, you I don't I don't care
about your autonomy in any way, shape,
or form when you're trying to you're
trying to get me to go. You're trying to
put assault charges on me from something
from eight months
ago. Uh, and they weren't even It wasn't
even assault. It was It wasn't even
assault. Okay, go. All right. Uh, go on.
Kind of glad you reached out. I was
contemplating not going further anyways.
So, thanks. We'll see if he's mean. I
was contemplating on not going further.
This is again she she This is at 2 2
p.m. She uh she was in at midnight on
the 2nd. So, what? Okay, never mind.
In case of an investigation by any
federal entities or similar, I do not
have any involvement with this group or
people in it. I do not know why I'm
here, probably added by a third party. I
do not support any actions by the
members of this group. Do not leak this.
Thank you, Darius. Looked up my name on
Russell search after work. Saw stuff
relating to your argument. I wanted to
clarify. I tested as recently as
December. I am completely clean and have
been my whole life and will show you
results if you need. I promise you I'm
not involved. Good luck with this awful
thing to go through. I had a scare for
Abby. It's hard to understand how a
person you might care about in some way
sees you as less than trash basically to
have leaked all this. Bit of a Yeah,
exactly. But like now I literally don't
feel bad about Darius getting his DMs
leaked from Zena. Like when Zena leaks
all of his DMs going totally insane mode
talking about himself with her. I don't
feel bad about reading any of those. I
don't feel I I didn't really already but
like he actually deserves it. Like I I
actually it felt a little bad but he
actually deserves it, right? He
absolutely deserves it.
There's no part of him that is a good
person. Um I I pray he can get away from
Destiny at some point and try to be his
own human being here with Hayden and it
turned out to be a UTI. Dude, seriously,
dude. Are you lied or not? I need to
talk. What are you doing?
About what?
I know you're hurting deep. I know
you've been hurting since way before I
ever met you. Since Sushi, this is
written with
AI. What the [__] M dash. Really? Okay.
since sushia and maybe even way before
that. But you've got to break this loop.
I don't follow you, but I know you're
trying food for people that have
Oh, the current state of the Destiny
orbit. Okay. These are Destiny's primary
shooters. Okay. Why is he dressed like
the fellow fellow kids
[Laughter]
meme? Did you see Desi retweeted Tom
today? There's a Destiny retweet on Tom
Foolery where Tom Fer is like Dean was
in my chat begging me to come on my
stream. I I was just like, "Dude, you
didn't let Dean on your stream. You have
you have like 6,000 followers on Tik
Tok," which is a lot or wait, hold on.
How How many does he have? Tom Fery Tik
Tok. Uh Tik Tok.com/tomfery show. Is it
6,000? It's 841. Sorry, it was almost
6,000 likes. He's got 841 viewers
followers. Why would he not let Dean on
his stream?
Why would you not pull Dean on your
stream and like have the chance of
blowing up? What
the
insane? Anyway, sorry. I'll let this uh
I'll let this read. I need to use the
bathroom really quickly. I'll be right
back.
About what? I know you're hurting deep.
I know you've been hurting since way
before I ever met you. Since Sushi, this
is written with
AI. What the dashing? Really? Okay.
since Sushia, maybe even way before
that. But you've got to break this loop.
I don't follow you, but I know you're
trying to for people that have that
sentence wasn't written with AI. Okay, I
know it's not your fault and I do feel
sorry for you. The people who understand
you best, who really get this this is
AI. I'm I'm telling you, by the way, who
really get the cycle of pain that comes
with love, no, it's not something you
just break out of overnight. When love
When you love someone as broken and as
much pain as Zena, and all you want to
do is help, but you just can't. You
don't really have a choice to leave for
your own health and happiness and for
everyone who else been affected. Nanny's
suffering really bad today. She's a
friend I met at the very end. She means
a lot to me now. It me to see her going
through similar stuff to what I went
through and others worse. Uh especially
knowing she doesn't deserve it. She's so
ignorant of this man. I'll do nothing
but protect her from as much as I can.
But I don't know. Uh real quick, she
tries I I so mad that she I even told
Nani I was like I don't know why you
ever talked to this girl. She started
talking to Nani because she started like
trying to Abby thinks she dealt with the
same thing that Nani had to deal
with again just like somebody who's
hurting and he's just like totally on
them because Destiny on a whim was like
you should leak
more. Oh my god.
Okay, sorry I didn't get water, but I
need to
because Zena is crashing out and trying
to like ruin Nani's life or whatever,
which is the only similar comparison
they have. Abby, I never had intention
to date. I was never going to date. I
was never talked about a relationship
with. Uh we kind of just like had like a
thing where we like talked at the start
and we kind of were like flirty,
flirtatious, like romantic,
semi-romantic or whatever. Uh, and then
like after like a little after like I
left uh Rhode Island, I there's
literally a log of me saying like, "Hey,
just, you know, you're being a little
bit too much. Uh, and I'm not going to
do I'm not going to pursue a
relationship with you because I think
you're way too clingy and I think you're
way too like uh like codependent. I
mean, I don't want I don't want to I
don't want I'm not going to I I can if I
go through the logs, I can pull up that
exact message." Uh, with Donnie, I That
makes this all okay, by the way. Okay,
that makes this all okay. Uh, you can
leak all of this because you didn't want
to date this girl long term. That makes
this all cool. That makes this all
awesome. Very much was considering a
relationship with her. We were talking
um about one at one point. Uh, and it
was like someone that was trying to like
do the thing. The only tie she has with
Nani is just as Cena.
All right.
Even if you block me or say horrible
things about me, I'll always care too.
And I know and understand now. I didn't
have the patience before, but I get it.
Protect Nani. Keep doing so. Please. I'm
encouraging her to change her number.
I'll help if I have to. I know how bad
that hurts. Just please think about how
bad it's hurting. Even if Zena's just
being skitso. We know she's nuts. I am,
too. So are you. But she needs serious
help. And she can't be hurting people
around you. I'm not your chatter. Do
what you want with your life. I'm not
your fan. I'll always care about you and
so will Gavin, but I'd hate to see you
destroy yourself more. Same you said to
me, that's why I care. Understandable. I
think you have to pay us for damages as
Denny doesn't get hit with it. 1,000 or
100.
Wait, did she delete messages?
This is not interesting. Yeah, well,
this part isn't interesting. Obviously,
the stuff from the beginning is very
interesting. I don't care about them
litigating like damages and from their
house.
So, I just can't believe I don't know
why in my head I'm like, Darius, how can
you be so like the primary part of this
when you've talked to Destiny on stream?
You make it seem like, hey, you had a
secret conversation. We know Destiny had
an off-stream conversation with Wes for
the first time in forever asking for
updates about Abby,
right? Like, that makes all of this look
incredibly
suspect. I think you're just you're too
concerned and overthinking too much. Oh,
in what way, Adam 66? Possibly, but I
don't know what we're talking about
there. I'm just saying this looks
suspicious. I thought this was like very
funny. Also, just like basically setting
up something. So, one, you know that uh
there on Abby, somebody who is
apparently going to be suing you, is a
already a sealed witness in your case.
The person you said was this person,
right? Or you were the first one,
Destiny, to say this is Darius's
roommate. Okay. And then not only that,
you're sitting in your chat and
commenting on this stream and driving
traffic to it. You're like driving your
audience to this
stream. I also think you're talking
about this too much. Just reach out to
Destiny if you feel obligated to
something. From your understanding of
the lawsuit, could Pixie's lawyers ask
for Destiny/ Darius's communications in
Discovery because of the stream, or is
it too late for that? I don't believe
it's too late. No, I don't think
Discovery's even ended.
I think they're still in
discovery. By the way, I don't think we
get all the discovery documents. I think
they request things back and forth,
right? Like in terms of they they have
conference and they request things back
and forth. I think it's only if they
have a dispute like we shouldn't have to
give you this, then they will produce
additional documents, right? Or then
then they'll do something through the
court. Yeah. So, like they're they're
literally in discovery right now as far
as I know. So, I don't see how this
could possibly be too late.
Anyway, all right. I think that is about
it for this. I don't think I had
anything else here. There is there are
logs of Destiny talking about how Abby
was like crazy for messaging him and he
had no idea why she was messaging him,
right? They're trying to first coers
this girl into just dropping her herit
to like remain friends with them. And
then when that doesn't work, they're
going to start humiliating and leaking
things about her, right? That's that's
more what I'm talking about. They're not
trying to win the case in in a legal
sense. They're trying to make her drop
out and go into hiding is what they want
to do,
right? Yeah. Nothing about the affidavit
changes at
all. Protective/confidentiality. I don't
have uh I can't buy documents on Pacers,
so I don't know what that
is. Okay. All right. I think that's it.
Again, I was looking for the one p I
can't remember if it was in logs or if
it was on a stream where Destie talked
about Abby reaching out to him. It was
like, this is this is crazy. I don't
even know if she's allowed to do that
without her lawyers being the ones to do
it. And uh and it turns out that Darius
is the one encouraging her repeatedly,
like actually manipulating her into
messaging Destiny. That looks
bad. Real quick, somebody sent it to me.
Okay. Or at least something close to
it.
Um I I'm about to find it. Hold on.
Makes more sense now. Oh my god, I just
had a brain blast. Some people have been
communicating with me privately that um
should I actually I don't give a [__]
now. They shouldn't be talking to me
privately and you So this is where after
after Darius bered Abby repeatedly to
contact Destiny privately after Destiny
reached out to Darius. Okay, this is the
10th of May. It's probably either from
the 10th or the 9th. Destiny decided to
go on stream and start maligning
somebody for contacting him privately.
Do you realize that it's like his guy
who is pushing this person who's like
trying to like actually threaten this
person like, "Hey, you blackmail me.
Hey, you you did this crime, too. Hey,
hey, you can't do this. It'll be a it
would be a nightmare for you. Should be
communicating only through your lawyer."
And the fact that they've been
communicating with me privately seems to
imply to me that there is a heavy amount
of pressure with opposing council to
elicit what I would say are obviously
false statements in order to keep this
case alive. And I think that
is I think I think I look forward to
showing up of the next court filing. It
feels to me like opposing council is in
over their heads. Don't work in this
area of law at all. This Joan Peters
person is a something kind of some kind
of immigration lawyer from Puerto Rico.
And this other guy I guess is just uh I
don't even know what law he does for
everything. Maybe car accidents. I don't
know. Um but they're in Man, he had such
a different energy when they applied for
this. Way over their head. Uh there's
way too much involved here. They don't
know basic rules of of civil procedure,
which I understand is civil probably is
your hardest law school class. I don't
know, maybe go back and and and take a
refresher on it. Um, and I think they're
at a point now to where I I legitimately
it feels like it feels like what they're
doing is they are grabbing random people
to perure themselves, but they're
telling the people, "We'll keep your
identity anonymous so everything will be
okay." Because some of these people have
expressed a great deal of the level of
uh insane. The level of
insane conspiratorial thinking here is
just
ridiculous. I don't So, by the way, we
now know that Darius would have leaked
these DMs to Destiny and then Destiny
would have uh read them and this was
like his reading of those DMs we saw
earlier tonight, right?
None of this is proven out by the DMs
that she got at all. It's just total
conjecture, right?
It's like you can just see how he's like
spinning the lies in real time. Yeah.
Uni. I don't know if he knows this, but
the motions are you you make a motion
and that is unilateral and then they get
to respond and then the judge will like
actually I don't know make a
decision. But
like how do you how do you just speak a
sentence unilaterally like that? No,
that's the actually the first step in
communication. You say something then I
say something and then we come to an
understanding over time. Oh my god. as
the full unredactive substantive content
of the Oh, sure, sure, sure. Anyway, we
don't need to go through more of this,
but I just thought it was funny that he
um that this is how he represented this,
right? We've now seen all the DMs that
he's referring
to. And we now know that he just spun
this conspiracy out of like literally
nothing.
Bonus meme. Brittany Simon really hates
Not So Ariodite. Okay. Uh let's see. We
got Britney on Not So Arerodite. Let's
check it out. an actual belief that she
thinks she is literally better than
other women and other women suck, but
she's one of the good ones. So much as
she believes that she could be the woman
to make misogynists think maybe women
aren't that bad. Kyla, I think in this
bubble, I think she thinks people need
her, which is why she has to do it. I
think the idea is like people need you
so they don't get radicalized. You are
on the left. All you can do is prove
your purity or be kicked out, right? And
so, do you get what I'm
saying? This is why I can't engage with
Kyla. What? And I know FD is trying to
make a bridge with Kyla, but I think
that's a mistake, too. I think making a
bridge with Kyla is the same as trying
to make a bridge with Kidology. It's
just not worth. As much as I dislike
Erdite, she is far less evil when it
comes to Britney. What did Britney do
that was evil?
She said really inappropriate things
about Destiny's kid. Other than that, I
actually don't know.
I legitimately don't know what she did
that was evil. She kind of sucks. She
kind of runs a cult. I guess maybe you
could say it's evil depending on how
cognizant you think she is of those
things.
I think she I think she's kind of Why
are we watching Aiden? Oh, true. Who's
got the
picture, bro? Somebody leaked me the
Britney only faked lupus once. Wait,
Britney faked lupus? She didn't have
lupus. That's too bad.
think selling your only fans to your
cult members is pretty bad. I think the
pseudootherapy plus uh only fan stuff,
yes, is uniquely taking advantage of the
uniquely vulnerable. But I'm just saying
in terms of like the content, in terms
of what she does, if you I guess aren't
in that pipeline, maybe we could say
that pipeline's pretty bad, too. But if
you're if you're not in that pipeline
from my perspective, like Britney's
pretty nonharmful. Like her group
doesn't like harass other people from
what I can see, right?
That is 100% evil. You can say it that
way. I think I
I'm having to readjust because I feel
like I attacked her when like her
comments publicly her comments publicly
don't make her evil. It might be that
her business model is evil. It's
possible. Okay. I've had to deal with
chat a lot in the last minute. I'm going
to listen again cuz I want to hear the
immediate criticism she makes. I don't
know that Kyla internalizes an actual
belief that she thinks she is literally
better than other women and other women
suck but she's one of the good ones so
much as she believes that she could be
the woman to make I do not believe that
like in terms of lesser evil that
Britney is the that either of them is
the lesser evil. I
think misogynists think maybe women
aren't that bad. Kyla I think in this
bubble I think she thinks people need
her which is why she has to do it. I
think the idea is like people need you
so they don't get radicalized. You are
on the left. All you can do is prove
your purity or be kicked out. Right? And
so do you get what I'm
saying? This is why I can't engage with
I don't understand the purity testing
that like the way we defeat purity
testing is purity testing, right? If
you're on the left, the only thing you
could do is be purity tested or get
kicked out. Show your pure or get kicked
out. Also, Hassan is out. Vant is not
pure. Kyla, what? And I know FD is
trying to make a bridge with Kyla, but I
think that's a mistake, too. I think
making a bridge with Kyla is the same as
trying to make a bridge with Kidology.
It's just not worth it for progressive
like goals. But I would say that's
because they aren't deconstructing
enough. I don't know where build this
peasants copper so Gidra can live on.
Oh,
well, thank God we're we're making that
money. And I don't know where Kyla will
be, but to me, they're probably not
going to be very left. No, Kyla can't
sit with us. She picked Destiny over
Hassan. She should have just picked
neither of them cuz they're both men and
useless. Then where's my bridges
episode? Wow. Miss Andre W. Notice that
Kyla never asked me to come on bridges
even though we were quote friendly.
Notice that Kyla never reached out to
me. Notice Kyla never wanted to build
the bridge with me. Right. What makes it
look like there are so many angry men is
the fact that a lot
unfortunately you decided against
Destiny. And that's realistically Kyla's
only moral compass. Okay. Are you with
Destiny or against him? Okay. Would you
talk to Destiny someday or not? If no,
you are unironically evil. a lot of men,
including Kyla, keeping friends with the
men who are predatory and who are
ultimately like upholding the patriarchy
in a bad way. And there's a reason Myin
and Destiny still got each other's back
and Kyla is is still has Steven's
back. You know what I mean? So, I don't
think it's like ah, she's kind of
spitting though, like a little bit. Like
I listen, I don't necessarily want to
agree with Britney wholeheartedly, okay?
But god
damn, because Kyla is a Destiny or a
Myin, but I think Kyla makes it look
like there's more of him. And that's the
thing is like Kyla asked when it was all
happening, she asked um Turkey to Tom,
am I supposed to abandon my friend?
That's why somebody like Kyla gets to
come on and say, "I'm actually the
college graduate. I'm actually the girl
who's not an OF model. Look at me. I do
podcasts with FD Signifier and CJ the X.
Like I'm not like these other girls.
Yeah. You know,
um Kyla and I had a good run together.
We had some good collaborations. I sent
her a letter just saying like your
constant supportive Steven after
everything he's done. It's just like too
much and I need to go in a separate
direction. I wish her the best and I
wish Kyla the best as well. I just wish
she wasn't spending it with all these
really gross men. And I do think that
Kyla does, from my understanding of her
work, desire to work with boys, does
desire to help men, and it can kind of
appear like a pickme a little bit with
Kyla. But I think what Kyla is doing um
is genuinely coming from a compassionate
place. I think that Kyla wants to help
men. The dilemma is that these men don't
care about her, don't care about her,
won't uplift her, and just don't give a
about her opinion. But I can't give Kyla
her flowers. Even though it it's
uncomfortable, you know, not trying to
take anything away from anybody. Kyla,
what are you doing, Kyla? But she's
doing it because and I have to By the
way, this is edited together. I have no
idea how it's edited if it's edited
together. Well, this I think she might
be a part of it. I'm just I'm sorry. I'm
losing track of like the sentences at
places where like it's not the same. Not
trying to take anything away from
anybody. Kyla like that. I don't know
where that cut is going to necessarily.
What are you doing, Kyla? But I would
just say for Riyle, I like videos like
this, but I know you edit them together
quickly. I think there should be some
more obvious thing in the transition
that like lets it uh if you'd add auto
transitions of some kind. She's doing it
because, and I have to accept this, I
think she might be a part of it. As much
as I want to believe Kyla is genuine and
maybe she's just naive, she is with
Steven. And Steven is the epitome of
playing the role.
Dude, Britney is like actually so so
base right now. Yes, I believe Kyle as
well where she was like, I'm just really
lost and I'm following my principles.
And like at some point I'm like, okay,
this doesn't make any sense anymore.
Like you're somebody who can't apply
like basic like some basic logic. You're
you're the person who worked in
addictions counseling, okay? Who's not
willing to force an addict to bottom tip
$3. Please unban I am poor. I live in
third row country. Sorry, Moonray
Murray. If you guys come in and do that
right after I say it, you you actually
just each forever until you've paid the
20. You might have to do $3 installments
for a couple months. Okay. But
unfortunately now you you've turned me
into the parent. I gave you the rules
and I didn't even want to enforce them.
I didn't want to ban you, but you like
actually asked me to ban you. Please ban
me and make me owe you $20. You asked me
for that. I don't know why you asked me
for that. I don't I actually didn't want
you
to. But unfortunately, I I gave the
rules and then you had to go against the
rules. So now I had to do what I said I
would do. It sucks. I wish we weren't
here.
He is cosplaying as a liberal or as a as
a progressive, right? This one time she
told me I'm like her she I remind her of
her dad and her dad has autism and I was
like well I have autism. Is Kyla neurode
divergent? Kyla's ner divergent ADHD so
that could play a role. Oh is she ADHD?
Because I've been wondering that like is
Kyla's neur divergence playing a role in
her naivity. Britney been throwing up a
lot of W's here so far. Britney please
do not do not excuse this because of
ADHD. Okay. Whoa. Is she on Bance? Is
that why she can't hold this person
accountable for any of their actions? Is
that what's Oh, I see. I don't think
she'd actually see. And also her desire
to sort of help people she sees who are
struggling, especially Destiny. Cuz
Destiny is the little boy she wants to
save. The question is why does she want
to save little boys? Yes. Like that's
the thing. It's like Destiny. Oh my god.
Britney Simon out here just absolutely
dunking. Okay. What
the? She's asking all the right
questions. I have a feeling she won't
have quite the inflammatory but correct
answers.
Kyla is trying to save.
I wonder if there could have been some
event in when Destiny was younger that
might have arrested his development and
could make him an adult little boy for
Kyla to save. Huh? But Kyla because she
wants to save boys. Chad says, "I think
what Kyla is saying is too nebulous and
vague to really gauge what her
relationship dynamic with Nick is."
Well, I have seen her relationship
conversations with Nick, as has my
Discord, cuz we've talked about them.
And I do think Kyla thinks she's married
to some hyper masculine man when in my
bubble, he's not.
I'll be real. I was I watched some of
this before and I watched and I felt bad
for going in on Britney like on behalf
of Destiny before, so I was giving her a
little too much charity. Yeah, the
business model is still the business
model still really now that I'm thinking
about it. But
anyway, go back to we'll go back to her
criticisms.
nebulous vague relationship dynamic with
Nick. Well, I have seen her relationship
conversations with Nick as
my Kyla thinks she's married to some
hyper masculine man when in my bubble
he's not. So, I think Kyla is uh in a
different bubble than me. When she talks
about Nick being this like very
masculine presenting man, I'm like, "In
what bubble?"
[Laughter]
Sips tea. In what bubble? sips tea.
In what bubble? You know what I mean?
Like in what bubble? So like we
obviously have differences without
looks, too. I also think Kyla's coping a
lot about her life. She also said she
fights a lot and I don't know what that
means in a marriage. Like I don't know.
I don't trust people who say they fight
in their marriages. Like I don't know
what that means. Oh. So when Kyla says
like, "Oh yeah, like fighting has made
our marriage stronger." I don't know
what that is. I don't know what you talk
about.
I don't know what you talking about,
Sipsy. I don't know what that is. I'm
not sure about that. Sips tea. Why does
she do this thing though? You notice
Kyla does this thing? Is this a
submissive action where she tries to
like head tilt and is she looking cute?
I don't
get, you know, I'll be honest. Before
she had her fall out with Destiny and I
was like kind of I didn't mind Britney
Simon content sometimes. Okay. Sometimes
the content's pretty funny. This is like
way overreading, but I love it. I love
watching just people overread like this.
Okay. Said she fights a lot. Like I
don't know what that means. So when Kyla
says like, "Oh yeah, like fighting has
made our marriage stronger." I don't
know what that is. I don't know what you
talk
about. Why did she do this thing though?
Oh, but did she do it there? I didn't
see her do it. Oh, this thing though.
You notice Kyla does this thing. Is this
a sub? Yeah, that's because she's trying
to adjust her back because it hurts
because she's carrying a lot of weight
that she wasn't carrying, you know, a
year and a half ago. Missive action
where she tries to like head tilt and is
she looking cute?
Sorry, that was a boob job joke, not a
getting fat joke. I don't get what she
she does that a lot. I wonder if it's
the microphone. Is she trying to see him
over the microphone? No, that was a that
was a boob job joke, not a not a not
anything else.
It's both. Well, it might have been
both, but intentionally just the just
the boob job joke. Okay, that was all it
was intentionally. Okay.